[Music]
so human beings have been building
clocks for millennia and it's it's it's
been in a long endeavor of our species
from sundials to our glasses to pendulum
clocks to arts watches to current atomic
clocks yet the brain has been telling
time since the dawn of of animal species
right so even even plants have the
ability to tell time in terms of
circadian clock so one of the mysteries
in neuroscience that many people are
studying is how the brain tells time so
in order to understand how the brain
tells time it's useful to quickly
remember how man made clocks work and
there's a vast diversity of manmade
clocks from pendulums to quartz watches
to atomic clocks and as diverse as these
things are they they share a common
principle an almost embarrassingly
simple principle which is just counting
the ticks of an oscillator so in the
pendulum you just count the ticks of the
pendulum up back and forth and the
quartz watch you're just counting the
mechanical vibrations of a quartz
crystal and in the case of atomic clock
it's a bit more complicated but they're
related to the oscillatory cycle of
electromagnetic waves so it's reasonable
to ask well it's not how the brain tells
time does the brain have some oscillator
that's ticking away in some circuit
that's counting those ticks and tocks
the answer is no the brain seems to have
fundamentally different ways of telling
time so the first thing to notice is
that while the mechanical clocks that we
make even your quartz watch can tell
time across the vast range of scales
from tens of milliseconds to hours
minutes and days and months and years so
the brain has many different clocks in
order to tell the
milliseconds and seconds and to tell the
time of days so one way to think about
it is the circadian clock the clock that
tells you what time of day it is and
when to arise and when to go to sleep
that doesn't have a minute hand much
less a second here
in contrast the clock that tells you the
timing device in your brain that tells
you hmm
this red lights taking a bit too long to
turn this traffic lights taking a bit
long to turn or I think the waiter
forgotten my coffee that clock doesn't
have an hour hand much less number of
days that have gone by so the brain has
different areas different mechanisms in
order to tell time we don't understand
fully understand how the brain tells you
what the tempo of a song is or when the
red light is going to change but it
doesn't seem to have to do with any
oscillator counter mechanism seems to do
with neural dynamics which is the fact
that patterns of neurons neurons are
coupled to each other neurons are
connected to each other and when you
activate some neurons that group of
neurons can activate another group of
neurons which can activate another group
of neurons so you can have these
evolving patterns of neural activity and
in the same way that if you throw on
throw a pebble into a pond it can create
this dynamical pattern and in a way that
pattern tells you how much time has
elapsed right you know that looking at
the pond if the diameter of those
ripples is large more time has elapsed
then if it's a little ripple so any
dynamical system in principle has the
ability to convey information about
elapsed time it's can be a timer so as
far as we know it seems that one of the
mechanisms that the brain uses to tell
time on the scale of hundreds of
milliseconds to seconds is through
neural dynamics and changing patterns of
neural activity neuron a activates
neuron B or checked-in rates neuron C
and you have these complex evolving
patterns so this is consistent with what
we call the multiple clock principle
which is the brain doesn't have any
master clock it has many different
circuits each specialized or that
that focuses on processing time on one
scale or another
[Music]